it's a pleasure to welcome back to the
program AC grayling who is master of new
college of the humanities London and
professor of philosophy as well as
author of the book the good state on the
principles of democracy it's so great to
welcome you back today
it's really great to be back nice to see
you then so maybe to begin with when we
think about the way that a democracy
should work where is modern Western
democracy falling short and maybe that
will serve to get us into the meat of a
lot of what you write Sean okay well all
you have to do is cast your mind back to
2016 and ask yourself some questions
about how could it be that two of the
one of the four table was the leading
democracies in the world United States
of America and the United Kingdom both
threw up a very very shocking results
through their democratic process you had
the the great blessing of Dora Trump
burst upon you and we had the great
blessing of brexit thrust upon us and
these were both by unexpected outcomes
and I think this shows symptomatic
really of the fact that our democracies
which in their in their inception of
course embody a really great idea their
idea that ultimately political authority
governmental authority lies in the hands
of the people the people constitute a
government the people arrange a
government to serve them and democracy
is meant to be not just by the people
which is what that suggests but it's
meant to be for the people and what
we've what we've seen is that government
isn't really for the people government
is for politicians of one faction or
another we compete with one another to
get their hands on the levers of power
to push through an agenda which suits
whatever factional interests they happen
to have and it's simply not clear any
longer that what we get out of the
democratic process is government for the
people now couldn't it be argued that
when you look at the examples you gave
brexit in the election of Donald Trump
that in a sense the process worked to
the extent that even though it seemed at
an early phase unlikely that Donald
Trump would be elected it seemed that an
early phase unlikely that brexit would
pass that they are results that came
from people choosing to vote or in the
case of Donald Trump many people chose
not to vote at all as we have only a 50
percent voter turnout here what what
about that argument that it is it is
maybe it didn't work out but it is
reflective of what the people wanted at
the time okay so that's a great
invitation to get into the mechanics of
how this thing is working yes both in
your country and in mind we have an
electoral system called the first past
the post electoral system sometimes
called a plurality voting system yes
this is a voting system which is deeply
undemocratic because if you cast a vote
for a losing candidate you are
completely unrepresented and we give you
an example supposing you have a
congressional district with a hundred
voters in it and ten people stand for
election each of whom get ten votes each
one gets nine votes and one gets 11
votes that's the person who goes to
Congress the person who got 11 votes the
other 89 people are completely
unrepresented add to this the fact that
in so many of your states you have a lot
of gerrymandering which means that
congressional districts hardly ever
change hands I mean something like 90%
of seats in the House of Representatives
never change hands from one party to the
other and you see that you get an
embedded two-party system and this
two-party system it gives power to one
or other of the party always on a
minority of the vote as my example of
the the plurality system shows this
turns a lot of people off this is why
you went only get maybe 50 office just
over 50% of people turning out to vote
in elections because they quite rightly
feel that their vote maybe won't count
for anything so the result is you get in
a better two-party system and the
two-party system can means that you have
two groups of people who are competing
with one another to get their hands on
government and this is exactly what
James Madison wrote about in the tenth
of the Federalist Papers when he talked
about the great dangers of factionalism
because it becomes a competition
political competition where the agenda
of one side of the argument is what's at
stake and not the interests of everybody
of the of the totality of people
participating in the good that
government should be serving so I'd love
to hear from you some ideas about voting
systems that you think would be
preferable to to first-past-the-post now
when it comes to the the situation you
talked about in a congressional district
or presidential election there are a
number of options that strike me as
better and I'm curious to hear which you
prefer with the case of brexit it seems
far more binary whether it's either exit
or remain and I don't know if I guess
I'm curious to hear from you whether you
believe that the voting system is also
at issue there yes well because we have
the peculiarity in United Kingdom that
we have an uncodified Constitution so
that the constitutional arrangements
that govern both general elections and
referendums are inconsistent they work
on different bases and different
referendums different referendums in the
last few years here have had either no
threshold or they've had a fresh
shoulder that no supermajority or they
haven't been binding that they've been
run on on different bases the 2016
brexit referendum resulted in 37% of the
total electorate voting to leave the EU
just 37% now in any mature advanced
political and constitutional order you
would expect a vote of that percentage
to be insufficient to trigger a massive
constitutional change of the kind that
breaks it represents you would consider
this to be below and any reasonable
threshold in fact in our own statutory
order here we place a minimum of a 40%
vote on a trade union for a strike for
example a 66% vote in Parliament for a
general election dissolution so a 37%
vote is insufficient and yet it was
taken by the party that wanted it to be
used for a brexit
process taking it as sufficiently
mandating and they just ran with it now
this is an example of the way that
unclarity in their constitutional
arrangements can be hijacked by this
kind of partisanship that democracy is
turned into instead of being democracy
being for the people it's for some or
other political faction and this is the
chief problem that we're facing now we
are going to go to a break on the
podcast and broadcast show and we will
continue our conversation with Professor
AC grayling on the YouTube channel where
the full discussion will be posted so
what would you like to see as a voting
system if it were up to you to configure
well I think a proportional system that
is one that reflects the diversity of
interests and needs and preferences in
the voting population where the voting
population is as extensive as it should
be I think anybody who can understand
what's at issue in an election and
that's anybody from the age of 16
upwards at very least should have a
chance to have a say their say their
voice should be equal to every other
voice so you need a proportional system
which equalizes the strength of all the
votes you have to be able to guard
against what could be called super
minority Arianism that is where you get
a system a bit like Italy or or Israel
work very very very small political
parties can hold the balance of power
and and in effect hold everybody else
hostage but it's not beyond the the wit
of human beings to come up with a system
and there are plenty of good examples in
Europe and European Union of
proportional systems which give rise to
coalition governments now a lot of
people argue against coalition
governments they say oh it's just horse
trading and you never get an indefinite
and so on but the truth of the matter is
the coalition governments are much much
more likely to result in satisfactory
compromises and in mature responsible
kinds of policies which play out in
economic and social terms to the benefit
of this
as a whole in fact there's empirical
evidence to this most of the countries
which have proportional electoral
systems and which typically have
coalition governments are among the most
successful in the world and again I mean
you can think of examples you can think
of the major European Union countries
which exemplify that also Germany the
Netherlands and a lot of places so this
is a this is a way of in fact draining
as much politics out of government as
possible it seems very unintuitive idea
because we're so used to you know
politics and politicking being the order
of the day but but when you consider
that entailment of the very concept of
democracy that the the the demos the
people are putting in place a government
to serve their interests to - you know
get there you know have their back
really look after what their best
welfare security enhancement economic
circumstances might be then instead of
just handing this over to party politics
- factionalism what you want is is
government which sees itself as and acts
accordingly as a body that serves that
the people and that's what I mean by
draining as much politics as possible
out of the process had governed when you
see a legislative body in the u.s. like
the United States Senate with 100
senators - from each state not
calibrated to the population of the
state of course the House of
Representatives has representatives
based on the population of the state in
the Senate it's two senators for each
state and you find yourself with the
situation like for example where
senators representing just seventeen
percent of the population could decide
that the president is not convicted on
impeachment as an example how does your
analysis apply to a body like the US
Senate well there are two ways to go on
the question of the Senate because your
account of it is absolutely correct it
says profoundly undemocratic body and as
such has far too much power in the
legislature
process you know in the United Kingdom
we have a completely unelected House of
Lords and but it has no power it has
hardly any power at all
it can't alternately block decisions
taken by the democratically elected
House and that's as it should be but in
your Constitution ah Riley you keep the
Senate as it is is the state's house
represent the interests of the states
rather than of the population but then
you have to reduce the amount of power
that it has and certainly that take away
the kind of power you've just described
a very small representation effectively
blocks and impeachment which on the face
of it is open and shut or you have to
make it much much more democratic the
other thing that an outsider looking at
the United States of America might say
and in fact two important things that
might be said and I do this with do
diffidence as a foreigner commenting but
but one is the Electoral College I mean
the electoral college was set up by
Hamilton at the very foundation of the
United States of America to ensure that
you wouldn't get ignorant ridiculous
idiots into the white house it was meant
to be a way of of protecting the the
country against having improper people
at the helm of the country and that of
course even from early in the 19th
century has never really effectively
worked because it's become captured by
the party political process as well and
the other thing is that tongue you know
I was talking about the uncodified
Constitution we have here in the UK
which because it's uncodified because it
consists of a lot of traditions and
conventions can be played by politicians
they can manipulate it apply it and
interpret it and base it suit their
needs of the day it seems to be the case
that the Constitution in our States of
America has become like holy which it's
very inflexible because the Second
Amendment I mean the arms in question
reference in the Second Amendment back
in the late 18th century were muzzle
loading muskets you know you can't do a
lot of harm with the muzzleloading
musket you might be
um one other person every few minutes or
so because you were in his stuff the
ball down the funnel their musket and so
on yeah it's pretty envisaged
Kalashnikovs and automatic rifles and so
on so there has to be some degree of
flexibility there has to be some way of
ensuring in any country when it thinks
about how its constitutional
arrangements are managed some way in
which flexibility and evolution with new
circumstances can be affected there's a
couple of other areas I wanted to
discuss with you
one is you talked about some of the
systems that exist in different
countries what are the countries that
have done the best job in terms of the
organization of the government that you
would consider models at least in some
sense for the direction you you like to
see the UK in the u.s. go okay well let
me preface what I say here by observing
that nowhere is perfect yes and in fact
it is extremely difficult to you know
counsel perfection in matters of
government and of politics because of
the competition of interests that there
are in any society this is a function of
a fact which is it's very important to
notice when one thinks about
constitutionality and politics and that
is that there is no such thing as a
majority in any society any society is a
collection of minorities and a majority
is just a temporary coalition of those
minorities for a certain purpose for
example on on Election Day this is why
civil liberties and human rights are so
important because rights of the rights
of individuals and of minorities no
majority no 51% of the country can say
well the other 49% we can just murder
them that we don't care about them
because we're the majority can't say
that again and because we're because any
society is a collection of minorities
they're always going to be a you know a
lot of competition some conflict and
disagreements different needs so it's a
great big kind of mosaic of of a
situation and that is why government is
quite hard it's quite hard to do it's
like herding cats so you're not going to
get
affection anywhere you can do your best
you can try to arrange things so that
government really will serve the
interests of the people not just at
one's part of the people and the kinds
of governments that do their best are as
I say the ones which have proportional
systems of representation and resulting
coalition kinds of governments and I've
already mentioned a couple in in Europe
Germany and the Netherlands for example
are good examples of this I think you
can look at other Westminster model
countries ones that base themselves on
the Westminster system about 50 of them
in the world but which have modified
that system like New Zealand for example
which is now got a more proportional way
of organizing its government and
therefore has a coalition style of
government and they are noticeably
successful you look at the Scandinavian
countries alongside New Zealand and you
notice there that they have the very
great advantage of relatively small
populations there all countries have
less than 10 million people where I
think democracy works best probably just
because government is much closer than
the people but if you're going to have a
democracy in a very big country like
United States
350 million people or so then you've got
to make sure that the electoral system
and that the the demands that are placed
upon the offices of government and the
people who occupy them but they said it
is actually clarity of what their duties
are and what the limits of their powers
are these things become crucial because
the great end of democratic government
is and I keep repeating this because
it's so important is to serve the people
not just Republicans not just Democrats
so not just one side of an argument or
not just career politicians I mean
here's a problem you know people go to
court politics as a career shouldn't be
it should be as a service last thing I
wanted to touch on what are the simplest
reforms that you favor which would
require the least sort of degree of
overhaul and imposition and consensus
that could
most readily be achieved okay that's a
great question actually because if you
try to reform too many things or all at
once you're going to reform nothing you
know you check the kitchen sink in there
you just obscure and confuse the issue
and you don't get anywhere so I think
that there are two key things and the
first of them perhaps the most important
one of them is reform of the electoral
system in all those democracies which
have the first-past-the-post system like
the US and like the UK and reform it in
such a way that that you don't get
Superman or at Arianism okay but where
you do get a genuine spread of
representation of the kinds of
preferences and choices that a very
diverse society will come up with and
then the governments that are formed on
the basis of that have to be governments
of compromise of working together of
seeking bipartisanship as to be try or
her partisanship or or whatever but in
order to satisfy the aim the demand that
they serve the interests of everybody
not just at one part is one thing and I
think the same thing that goes along
with it is we really really do need to
have a look at the media now I think you
are lucky in the United States America
luckier than we are in the UK because
you have some verifying newspapers like
the New York Times and The Washington
Post our great admiration for them
you've got some broadcasters like CNN
who do a good job
you've got examples of the kind of media
which pump out misinformation and
falsehood and partisanship and so on
like Fox so that's a problem but but
we're kind of overloaded with foxes in
the UK we have that what we call the
tabloid press here which is really low
level and it poisons the public
discourse so if you don't get the kind
of clear clean useable information which
is essential to a democracy but worst of
all of course of course is what we're
making use of at this very moment which
is social media and because one
prominent mean it's oh you mean it can't
be great and at the moment is keeping
everybody in touch with one another in
they're in this bad time but it can also
be abused so for example
I can use big data analytics to
micro-target to groups of people with
misinformation with false promises with
lies and other people can't see what I'm
targeting and therefore they can't call
me out and this is a very dangerous
thing that the democratic process
because it undermines it truth and fact
are essential for democracy so the
second thing that we would need
alongside really good electoral systems
is clean information we've been speaking
with Professor AC grayling the book is
the good state on the principles of
democracy we are linking to it on our
website and in the description for the
YouTube video for the interview so great
to have you on and I really appreciate
your time today
thanks very much David really good to
see you